all right here with reaction all this
breaking news today he is the host of CR
TV's Levin TV and right here on the Fox
News Channel number one show Sunday
nights 10:00 Eastern I call him the
great one Mark Levin life liberty and
Levin is the name of the show alright so
we have this appointment of Robert
Muller by Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein because sessions is recused
you have been saying in the last 24
hours on your radio show and you told me
privately that this very well violates
our Constitution and more specifically
the appointments clause and I want you
to really explain this to our audience
tonight
first of all this seed was planted with
me by hat tip to Professor Steven
Calabresi an old friend of mine who
worked for Attorney General meets as
well we have in the Constitution
something called the appointments clause
and it applies to principal officers of
the executive branch there's inferior
officers you know like a chief of staff
an administrative assistant who reports
to a principal then there's principal
officers as an example every single
United States Attorney in the United
States has to be nominated by the
president United States and confirmed by
the Senate because our founders make
clear that they wanted both branches of
government involved in appointments of
the senior level people you have
assistant secretaries and departments
deputy secretaries and apartments and of
course cabinet secretaries and I said US
Attorney's here's the problem the
appointment of Muller is utterly
unconstitutional for a number of reasons
rod Rosenstein gave him an agenda that
is so broad not a specific individual
not a specific statute not even a
specific matter and not only was the
initial appointment incredibly broad he
keeps expanding it so it's this special
counsel is different than past special
counsels he's more like a roving US
Attorney also we learned something today
that's absolutely incredible in Politico
it says several court filings indicate
that when lawyers for mullahs office
appeared in federal court in Alexandria
earlier this year they did so not only
as representatives of Muller's office
but they received an appointment a
special assistant United States Attorney
appointment in the Eastern District of
Virginia they are in effect assistant in
state's attorneys Robert Muller wanted
to expand their power they report to the
hem if their assistant united states
attorneys are special assistants United
States attorneys that make smaller
without question the equivalent of the
United States attorney so what's unique
about him and pass independent counsel
and special counsel is the massive
breadth of his investigation he's going
into bank fraud wire fraud he's going
into rush he's going into a number of
other countries he's interviewed
hundreds of individuals tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
documents he's not an inferior employee
like an administrative assistant or or
anything of that sort he is a principal
officer and under the appointments
clause of the United States Constitution
Article two Mr Rosenstein usurped the
authority of the President of the United
States to nominate whomever he wants as
a prosecutor and mr. Rosenstein usurped
the power of the United States Senate
which has the control of her
confirmation or not mr. Muller is
serving unconstitutionally in violation
of the appointments clause of the
Constitution because of the way
Rosenstein appointed him because of
expanding his authority because mr.
Muller has expanded his own authority
with these for now assistant United
States Attorney's and every defendant in
this case every witness in this case
everybody who receives a subpoena in
this case whatever federal court it is
should raise the issue of the
appointments clause of the Constitution
of that mr. Muller is conducting himself
and his appointment is unconstitutional
see here's the deal these career
bureaucrat prosecutors like Rosenstein
and Muller and Comey they don't
understand the Constitution they
understand parts of it like due process
warrants subpoenas probable cause which
will never read the appointments clause
they've never read the Supreme Court
decisions involved in that like marcin
versus Olson and so forth I had
professor Calabrese he has I want your
audience to know this too so mr. Muller
unlike any past special counsel and like
any past independent counsel his the
breadth of his investigation is so
massive it's so broad by the initial
appointment the subsequent expansion and
now for of his own people
getting dual appointments as effectively
Assistant United States Attorney's mr.
Muller his conduct his appointment is
unconstitutional you know that's why I
call you the great one what you say I
hope every attorney involved in this
case heard you and if you're out
watching tonight when this is up on
foxnews.com please tweet it out please
use social media please make sure this
goes viral and all you attorneys out
there go for it baby I know what I'm
talking about that's why we call you the
great one life Liberty Levin it's every
Sunday night I'm gonna be a guest in a
coming edition with the great one more
my friend thang